dos oficiales de la policía
metropolitana y dos de la policía del
capitolio compartieron sus versiones de
lo que vivieron y afirmaron que no se
puede avanzar ni superar lo que pasó si
no se sabe exactamente lo que pasó el 6
de enero hubo 140 policías heridos y
hasta ahora 550 personas han sido
acusadas de crímenes sin embargo quedan
muchas preguntas sin resolver y los
nueve miembros del comité bipartidista
creado para indagar lo que ocurrió
tratarán de responder quién estaba
detrás de los atacantes que a nivel de
preparación y de advertencia tenían los
policías cuando se enteraron los
políticos de los inminentes ataques y
cuáles fueron sus respuestas y la
pregunta sobre todo si hubo coordinación
entre algunos atacantes y algunos
miembros de el congreso el comité
también está considerando llamar como
testigos a congresistas republicanos que
hablaron con el expresidente donald
trump en pleno ataque el 6 de enero